jean pierre raffarin invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir monsieur le premier
ministre
bonsoir oui merci d'être avec nous et de
nous réserver d'ailleurs votre première
réaction au plan choc dévoilé dimanche
soir tard françois hollande pour
atteindre donc le cap des 3% de déficit
public l'an prochain et faire reculer le
chômage dès l'année prochaine
l'ump a refait on l'a vu son unité le
temps des critiques contre l'exécutif
mais la compétition bien sûr se poursuit
pour la présidence du parti frédéric
dumoulin de l' agence france-presse
notre partenaire vous interrogera tout à
l'heure sur votre soutien à jean
françois copé
et puis troisième partie de preuves par
3 avec perrine tarneaud de public sénat
on prête à la droite l'ambition de
regagner le sénat dès 2014 première
élection intermédiaire avec les
municipales je note que les
téléspectateurs peuvent également
intervenir durant cette émission par le
biais de l'application tivi tchèque de
notre partenaire orange alors françois
hollande s'est il selon vous monsieur
raffarin réveiller des deux yeux que
d'un oeil disiez-vous avant son
intervention sur tf1
moi j'ai trouvé très franchement que
l'émission n'était pas mauvaise je pense
que la dimension économique du discours
du président a été renforcée je pense
que ce qu'il a pu voir cet été
l'aggravation de la crise dont convaincu
qu'il fallait muscler le discours
économique ce qui a été fait il ya
encore beaucoup à faire mais je dois
reconnaître que de ce point de vue là
j'ai trouvé la bataille engagée contre
la dette contre le chômage c'était un
discours clair je regrette beaucoup
l'absence du mot europe à en imposer ma
question
enfin on n'a pas besoin de poser la
question quand on parle de la crise pour
ça rires aujourd'hui le sujet essentiel
c'est europe euro emploi et revenir mais
emploi et europe c'est un sujet sur la
bataille d'ailleurs françois hollande
lui-même a dit qu'il était en situation
de combat
qu'est ce que vous pensez des armes
qu'il devait utiliser c'est à dire quand
même une pression fiscale accrue
venez japon si lorik et puis également
des économies budgétaires je pense qu'il
fait une erreur pédagogique en ne
coupant pas la poire en deux entre
l'état et la fiscalité
et tant qu'à chercher 30 milliards je
pense qu'il aurait cherché 15 milliards
dans l'économie de l'état et 15
milliards par la fiscalité à partager
entre les entreprises et les ménages
c'eût été plus convaincant là on sent
que l'état fait un effort mais c'est
l'effort qui est là finalement la moitié
des forts de femmes moindre et pas quand
même le satisfecit que vous délivrez ce
n'est pas un satisfecit mais je ne suis
pas satisfait je trouve que on a perdu
beaucoup de temps je trouve que la
france perd du temps ce moment je pense
que le président
je pense que le président doit
aujourd'hui est plus actif plus engagé y
compris sur la scène européenne
mais je dis très clairement que ce n'est
l'intérêt de personne que le président
la république dans la situation de crise
dans laquelle nous sommes pas des contre
performances à la télévision et on perd
du temps il faut se réveiller mais si
nous en sommes là jean pierre raffarin
c'est que la dérive vient de loin et
même depuis 2002 on a vu la dette
s'envoler le déficit se creuser est ce
que la droite doit quand même
reconnaître sa part de responsabilité
mais avant même la crise et il est il
est clair que la crise a été très
importante je pense que nous avons fait
un certain nombre d'efforts nous avons
connu un certain nombre de difficultés
mais je crois vraiment que dans ces cent
jours
pour le président il y a beaucoup de
temps perdu et je pense qu'il n'y a pas
de lisibilité sur son combat européen
que veut-il il voit mal à merkel oui il
va monsieur monty oui il va en espagne
oui mais pour dire quoi où le combat
clair il faut évidemment aujourd'hui
mutualiser nos dettes mais il faut faire
des efforts quel est l'effort de la
france qui est fait pour crédibiliser sa
parole notamment souffert le plus vif
mais de 120 % de recettes ce qui suit
cette crédibilité il faut le dire madame
merkel il faut pouvoir dès le début de
l'été clairement envoyé le message à nos
partenaires et aux marchés à ceux qui
ont fait confiance à la france en lui
prêtant de l'argent qu'on va vraiment
répugnant et là on a entendu
l'annnonce de dépenses nouvelles
'l'annonce d'un certain nombre de de
perspectives qui sont des perspectives
lente c'était tout ce message de l'été
et est même le message de la rentrée on
va trouver pour l'éducation des moyens
nouveaux et oui matt hill et trouver
monsieur rousset moyens nouveaux et donc
on a entendu un certain nombre de
disques au laxisme
je pense qu'il est grand temps d'avoir
un langage de vérité
le président a fait un tout petit bout
du chemin
je m'en réjouis mais il faut qu'il aille
beaucoup par certains économistes de
tous bords d'ailleurs disent qu'il faut
peut-être revoir cet objectif de
réduction du déficit public parce que ça
nous mène tout droit à l'austérité
c'est une crainte je pense que cette
analyse là n'est pas exacte non je pense
que la crise elle va venir de manière
extrêmement brutal quand les taux
d'intérêt vont monter
c'est en dire quand la france va être
dans la situation il y aura plus de
confiance j'ai lu la presse
internationale
la faire arnaud et dévastratrice pour
l'image de la france dans le monde c'est
du niveau des 35 heures parce que si ce
qu est un grand groupe comme dior comme
toutes les grandes mains de se regrouper
levée est marche n'a pas confiance dans
la france comment voulez vous que les
autres aient confiance dans la france et
je vous assure garder la presse
asiatique la presse américaine on a le
sentiment comme dit jean pierre
chevènement les élites n'ont plus
confiance dans la france on se dit les
entrepreneurs n'ont plus confiance dans
pc vous dites-vous un bernard arnault le
patron de l
mach pour qu'il reste pleinement en
france je pense que le message de son
attachement à la france a été envoyée je
pense qu'il doit être en permanence
réaffirmé il est clair que la situation
dans laquelle nous sommes de scepticisme
sur l'avenir de la france y compris de
la part des élites de la france est
extrêmement grave
on ne mesure pas combien l'étranger
aujourd'hui nous regardent ils
n'oublions pas que notre dette
contrairement la dette japonaise c'est
une dette qui est à l'étranger et si
l'étranger on veut qu'ils aient
confiance au moins nous affichons notre
confiance avoir créé les conditions qui
ont conduit monsieur ardo à faire cette
déclaration c'est une responsabilité
certes de monsieur arnaud mais pas
seulement alors françois hollande a bien
précisé qu'il maintenait donc cette
taxation des très hauts revenus au
dessus du milliard d'euros à 75%
vous vous critiquer cette mesure même si
elle est provisoire et qu'elle est faite
au nom du patriotisme par le chef de
l'état je pense que cette mesure a des
conséquences sur le plan économique qui
démobilise nos élites économiques et que
c'est vraiment très grave
et quand je vois un grand quotidien
comme libération qui titre casse-toi
riche qu'on j'ai vraiment mal à mon bon
sens à l'honneur du pays mais j'ai aussi
le sentiment qu'on donne là une image de
la france qui n'aime pas la réussite qui
n'aiment pas le succès est au fond c'est
ce qui décourage tout le monde de venir
participer au développement de notre
pays et tout ça ça conduit à quoi un
risque d'augmentation des taux d'intérêt
et le jour où nous taux d'intérêt
augmenteront et bien nous serons dans
une extrême difficulté financière alors
le chef de l'état a présenté son agenda
social 1 avec à la clé d'ici la fin de
l'année il l'a dit des réformes de
structure il veut un choc de
compétitivité d'autres mesures sont
annoncées en débat d'ailleurs déjà au
parlement
c'est par exemple les emplois d'avenir
est ce que vous y êtes favorable pour
les jeunes qui
ne sont pas ou peu qualifiés je ne suis
pas favorable à ce projet mais je
voterai le texte de loi
je ne suis pas favorable parce que
j'aurais été favorable à d'autres
projets je l' ai déjà dit pendant la
campagne électorale il y à une solution
qui me paraissaient meyer qui était de
conditionner les allègements de charges
liés aux 35 heures que dont bénéficient
les grands groupes de conditionner ces
allègements déjà al embauche de jeunes
cons alternance dans des vraies
entreprises avec de vrais emplois
c'était ça notre perspective c'était ça
ma conviction mais je ne vais jamais
voté contre un texte qui donne des
emplois des jeunes je ne vais pas mettre
un barrière sur un chemin que je c'est
difficile je sais qu'aujourd'hui une
première expérience ce n'est pas
forcément un emploi mais c'est une
marche vers l'emploi et donc de ce point
de vue là je ne sens pas je me sens pas
le droit d'interdire ces taxes est déjà
longue je voterai ce texte
j'aurais fait autrement mais ce n'est
pas une solution mais c'est une marche
vers l'emploi et je me sens pas le droit
de dogo poser à cette démarche et vous
pensez de l'incohérence de certains élus
ump qui veulent voter contre les emplois
d'avenir mais qui veulent localement les
utiliser dans leurs collectivités
ok j'ai vu ça avec les socialistes j'ai
vu ça dans tout débat politique quand on
a un peu d'expérience on sait qu'il vaut
mieux mettre ces votes au parlement en
cohérence avec sa version locale
moi je sais que sur le terrain dans ma
permanence quand je voudrais proposer à
des jeunes en difficulté d'aller
chercher un emploi d'amir vaut mieux que
j'ai voté le texte plutôt que je sois
hostile au texte
qu'est ce qu'on pensait du pari de
sauver l'état qui mise sur une inversion
de la courbe du chômage dans un an alors
que la croissance nécessaire n'est pas
et ne sera pas au rendez vous il ne
prend pas les moyens de ses objectifs
l'épreuve risque politique majeur mais
bon je pense qu'il prend un risque
politique majeur mais je crois que d'une
manière générale et cet été un peu
léthargique du gouvernement me laisse
penser qu'ils n'ont pas pris conscience
de l'ampleur de la crise qui nous attend
avec les difficultés majeures dans un
grand nombre d'entreprises
quand on voit que on a eu des discours
sur psa que cette ses licenciements
était inacceptable qu'on voit ensuite on
joue demandait de limiter là que la
réalité s'impose aux uns et aux autres
je pense que le gouvernement doit être
content
on de cela et je pense qu'il faut aider
les entreprises il faut aider les pme et
je vais vous le dire on n'a plus
beaucoup d'argent aujourd'hui dans
l'état pour aider les entreprises
alors qu'on les aide en allégeant les
charges les contraintes les normes les
procédures par exemple des seuils à 50
comporte ces seuils de 50 à 100 faisons
en sorte qu on donne des libertés aux
entreprises il ya un certain nombre de
libertés qui ne coûte rien à l'état
est-ce que vous avez vu dimanche soir
françois hollande tourner la page de la
présidence normale on l'a vu un
c'est autoritaire martiale même mêmes on
peut s'interroger sur la place
aujourd'hui du premier ministre non je
pense que le président a fait une
émission en bon professionnel mais je
n'ai pas trouvé qu'en termes de
leadership il avait encore atteint
l'ensemble des caractéristiques de la
fonction et donc je pense que il est en
train d'apprivoiser la fonction oui
m'enfin je n'ai pas trouvé que se dégage
et le leadership dont le pays a besoin
en période de crise et je pense que
l'organisation institutionnelle de notre
pays n'est pas encore stabilisée je
pense que le rôle du premier ministre
rôle des ministres ne sont pas encore
aujourd'hui suffisamment stabilisé pas
suffisamment opérationnel est votre
commentaire sur la façon que je monsieur
ayrault d'occuper la fonction de premier
ministre monsieur raffarin
je pense que monsieur euro doit définir
clairement dans le sud qui la porte mais
c'est quelqu'un de respectable c'est
quelqu'un qui a de l'expérience il est
maire de nantes
il a présidé le groupe socialiste donc
ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui est léger
dans la fonction mais c'est quelqu'un
que je crois n'a pas encore défini ce
qui doit apporter véritablement à cette
équipe
moi je m'attendais à ce qu'il soit un
peu un leader en matière de relations
franco allemandes
or c'est le sujet numéro un de l'été
c'est le sujet numéro un de la crise est
là très peu d'action très peu
d'initiatives ont peu je vois qu'il fait
ni une percée à marseille on s'y
installe en 48 heures il peut jouer
comme moi c'était le cas la carte de
l'élu provincial du maire parmi les
maires de quelqu'un qui était lui cela
tient je pense qu'il peut trouver des
voies de singularité pour montrer
luminescence émission je ne donne pas de
conseils
ce que je dis c'est que pendant l'été le
gouvernement n'a pas donné le sentiment
d'être au travail et on avait le
sentiment qu'ils avaient eu dix ans pour
prendre des vacances
et là on les a trouvés léthargie je ne
sais pas mais mon petit doigt me dit que
votre préférée au sein du gouvernement
c'est manuel valls c'est quelqu'un que
respectant mes du nom mais lorsqu'au vie
sinon mais il ya des gens il ya des gens
corrects il ya des gens pour
probablement à 400 acteurs et un certain
nombre de gens qui sont pas menacer la
même politique non en matière de
sécurité il a déclaré aujourd'hui que la
france ne peut pas accueillir toute la
misère de l'europe
fermeté absolue vis-à-vis des roms oui
ça c'était une déclaration de michel
reprises qu'on a beaucoup cité par la
suite donc c'est quelqu'un qui a des
qualités mais enfin il est plus facile
de se faire bien pouvoir en faisant une
politique de droite une politique de
gauche et c'est à l'intérieur notamment
et c'est ce que valls est en train de
mesurer et donc je comprends que cela
ait une réaction intelligente il va là
où il ya une demande en cette rentrée
est ce que le holland bashing nous a
paru plus violent que la sarkophobie à
l'époque où je trouve que le
gouvernement s'est donné quelques
attitudes qui ont conduit à ce résultat
et donc quand le cheval trébuche c'est
toujours le cavalier qui est responsable
entre il faut pas accuser les chevaux
mais le cavalier doit pouvoir mener une
allure qui évite les critiques allaient
nous allons parler maintenant de la
compétition pour la présidence de l'ump
monsieur raffarin avec deux moulins de
l' agence france-presse va nous
rejoindre mais d'abord la campagne
acharnée dominé donc par ce duel copé
fillon avec paul bouffard c'est une
campagne qui ébranle l'ump depuis
plusieurs semaines les candidats à la
présidence du parti ont fait de cette
course un véritable pugilat
tout le monde veut être l'héritier du
sarkozysme dans la course à la
présidence les chefs se font la guerre
d'un côté jean françois copé le
secrétaire général de l'ump continuent
d'attaquer l'ancien premier ministre lui
s'oppose aux candidats des barons de
l'ump jean françois a raison de se poser
en candidat du peuple militant le peuple
le militant qui n'a pas se laisser
dicter de choix par les sondages sur les
sympathisants étaient dans le camp
fillon on est-il que la ligne jaune est
franchie par jean-françois copé
c'est vrai que ces derniers temps un
grand nombre d'élus ont rejoint la
candidature de françois fillon est
appelé à soutenir cette candidature mais
si ces élus appellent à soutenir
françois c'est peut-être tout simplement
qu'ils écoutent leurs militants et
peut-être tout simplement que françois
fillon est le chouchou de leurs
militants et au milieu de ce duel à
couteaux tirés
la démocratie a du mal à trouver sa
place
plusieurs ténors du parti interpelle le
secrétaire général sur l'organisation de
la campagne sur les conditions du
scrutin certains des petits candidats
tentent d'exister pour eux difficile de
faire entendre leurs projets bien
entendu je suis un petit candidat je
n'ai pas la notoriété d'un françois
fillon ou d'un jean françois copé c'est
normal les petites phrases du camp
fillon contre le camp copé du camp copé
contre le conte fillon moi c'est pas ma
tasse de thé débat d'hommes plutôt que
débat d'idées pour l'instant l'ump et
loin de l'unité
l'air de rien à l'arrivée le 18 ou le 25
novembre
théoriquement on se rassemble basse et
on continue comme ça le rassemblement va
être difficile et donc nous sommes
encore loin de la ligne d'arrivée à et
le combat est âpre bonsoir frédéric
dumoulin de l' agence france presse
qu'il suisse
cette compétition comment l'avez-vous
présidence de l'ue justement on l'a vu
dans le reportage la campagne officielle
n'a pas encore commencé et on voit déjà
que c'est très tendu entre les deux
camps principaux c'est-à-dire fillon et
copé
certains parlent même d'une bataille un
peu à la chirac balladur vous ça vous
fait penser à ça aussi ou pas rien un
peu de ça oui il ya une campagne très
terrain très contacts personnels puis
une campagne plus médiatique
je dirais qu'il ya une campagne celle de
françois fillon qui est plus
présidentiel et une campagne de jean
françois copé qui est plus municipal
inoxia un parallèle entre avec chirac
balladur ouvriers plutôt jean françois
copé dans le rôle de chirac
jamais deux fois dans le même fleuve
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai qu' il est
clair que jean françois copé a une
attitude de faire de la politique
un peu comme jacques chirac c'est-à-dire
dans la chaleur humaine dans la
convivialité dans le contact vous
utilisiez au moins 2 au mois de juillet
vous avez dit il ya du chirac en lui
c'est absolument il a ce côté
et quand on voit son équipe je voyais ce
matin de travail et c'est dès qu'une
équipe qui est très jeune d'ailleurs qui
est beaucoup plus jeune que l'équipe
fillon je crois au au total et c'est en
plus une équipe cas liés par un lien
affectif et vous pensez qu'au final il y
aura finalement que deux candidats ou
alors
il peut y en avoir d'autres bah je ne
sais pas ce que ça serait vraiment un
problème
je pose est bien entendu tout ce qui
rentre est qu'il ya un duel mais tout
cela ont notamment participé à nos
statuts et qui sont complètement
inspirée par la famille de notre
construction qui était la famille très
attaché aux institutions de la vème
république et on a choisi à l'ump des
institutions comme la vème république
c'est-à-dire un duel avec deux candidats
au second tour et deux candidats
seulement donc de toute façon notre
débat se terminera par un duel puisqu'il
n'y a que deux candidats au second tour
alors aux condamnés trois fin d'année 4
moi je ne suis pas contre un problème
démocratique vous dis je pensais toute
façon nous avons pris les institutions
de la vème république
elles sont démocratiques et un scrutin
présidentiel à deux tours avec deux
candidats au second tour
c'est ce qui est dans nos institutions
un jour tu as sur ce qui se passe au
parti socialiste puisque on critique
beaucoup le manque de démocratie enfin
dans la procédure à l'ump qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la façon qu'a retenu le
parti socialiste qui demain annoncera
donc le successeur de martine aubry
écoutez je pense que c'est une affaire
qui se traitent entre notables entre
barons d'hier et aujourd'hui et pas
entre militants donc c'est regrettable
au moins je pense que l'élection de
l'ump et le congrès de l'ump va être
décidé par les militants et pas par les
notables donc de ce point de vue là je
pense que l'ump est plus militante et
plus dans la proximité que le parti
socialiste mais je voudrais attirer
votre attention sur un point très
important de notre congrès pour moi
l'élection présidentielle du l'ump est
important mais ce n'est pas l'essentiel
pourquoi parce que de toute façon le
candidat qui sera élu devra être
éligible dans trois ans et que quant au
choix du candidat à la présidentielle il
devra être choisi par des primaires en
2016 donc pour moi le plus important au
congrès c'est en découvrant le
rassemblement par l'émotion deux
courants qui vont être créés et je peux
vous annoncer ce soir que le courant
humaniste centriste libéral a réussi à
se rassembler on présente
sur une motion demain et donc 2 jean
leonetti à marc philippe daubresse en
passant par luc chatel marc laffineur
avec donc toute cette famille qui est
une famille non seulement des centristes
des libéraux mais aussi des gens comme
marie hélène des esgaulx empêche qui
sont des gaullistes sociaux
nous avons là une motion qui rassemble
plus de 80 parlementaires plus de 80
parlementaires ce sera sans doute une
motion parmi les plus larges qui sera
présenté et de ce point de vue là je
pense que ce sera l'innovation
le second fait normalement vous devriez
avoir un bon score vous pensé au moins
je pense notamment en ayant rapproché
la motion que je conduisais avec celle
que conduisait luc chatel je pense que
nous devrions faire un bon score et
c'est très important je vois que tout le
monde n'est pas favorable au mouvement
dans l'ump
je vois que françois fillon est hésitant
j'ai entendu que nathalie que j'aime
beaucoup être contre les courants - je
pense que la survie l'avenir de l'ump
passe par les courants et par la
diversité sans courant l'unité de
lui-même et il serait une mise en péril
vous pensé justement que le courant
humaniste libéral centriste est
majoritaire à l'ump je ne pense pas
qu'il soit majoritaire nous verrons mais
en tout cas il peut être celui qui
arrivera en tête dans l'ump
en tout cas nous avons comme ambition
d'être le courant qui arrivera en tête
dans l'ue appelle c'est une bataille
difficile mais nous avons alors à
populaire et devant le jeune je pense
que tu en tout cas nous nous battons
pour la première place
nous représentons la france moderne et
humaniste et cette france moderne et
humaniste dans l'ump à l'espoir d'être
le premier courant mais le candidat que
vous ne soutenez pas donc françois
fillon a mis en garde contre une
balkanisation de l'ump en raison de ces
courants que vous défendez oui mais je
pense que moi je mets en garde contre
une uniformisation une caporalisation de
l'ump et donc je ne crois pas que
l'alignement de l'ump sur un seul
courant historique soit vraiment
l'avenir de l'ump
je pense que nous sommes assez
responsables pour faire de notre
diversité une capacité d'unités c'est
moi je pense que le choix des courants
est un choix stratégique
je fais confiance à jean françois copé
non seulement c'est mon ami il a été mon
ministre c'est la raison principale
c'est un élément politique objectif
c'est lui qui veut créer un levier
courant c'est lui qui a une vision
originale d'une famille politique qui
doit assumer sa complexité
et c'est pour ça qu'il peut compter sur
moi l'avion n'a jamais été votre mise
j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec lui on a
fait beaucoup de choses ensemble
mais en l'occurrence je choisis la jeune
génération je pense que la génération
qui est la mienne qui à quelques
expériences doit participer au
renouvellement de l'ump il y as autour
de jean françois copé une équipe très
jeune j'ai beaucoup d'amitié pour luc
chatel
je vois qu'il ya là un potentiel et je
crois que pour préparer l'avenir
la vie politique c'est très dur exercer
des responsabilités au sommet de l'état
c'est très difficile il faut se préparer
et pour ça il faut choisir les jeunes
justement celui que vous soutenez est-ce
que vous pensez que les sondages qui
sont quand même très fortement en faveur
de monsieur fillon ils sont réalisés sur
les sympathisants est ce que vous faites
partie des gens qui fait une réelle
distinction entre les sympathisants et
les militants seuls les militants étant
amenés à voter au moment du congrès
d'abord je vous dirais que dans ma vie
politique j'ai toujours choisi mes
convictions dans les sondages
quand j'ai choisi risque à chirac et
sarkozy pour la présidentielle
tous les trois étaient en retard dans
les sondages donc c'est pas le sondage
qui fait ma conviction c'est ma
conviction qui m'engage pour cela je
crois que c'est vrai que sympathisants
et militants il faut faire une
différence c'est vrai que d'une manière
générale je dirais que plus on fréquente
la permanence de l'ump dans la
circonscription
plus on est proche de jean françois copé
plus on est proche du travail de terrain
du travail militant plomb et proche de
jean françois copé et plus on s'éloigne
vers des fonctions plus nota plus
sympathisante plus plus et lui peut-être
un peu plus lointaine plus en et filles
ont donc je pense qu'on est allé jusqu'à
dire comme certains copéiste et je vais
vous étonner mais pas rond que mais je
fais mais si on veut c'est pas parce que
c'est pas parce que vous êtes blond vous
n'aimez pas les bras
chacun à son profil non peut être
quelqu'un ouvert où elle m'arrive
d'aimer ce que je ne suis pas et donc il
m'arrive d'être ouvert aux autres et
donc là moi je vais bien je suis en
effet un baron mais il se trouve que je
suis aussi j'ai le coeur militants est
en tout cas je choisis l'avenir je
choisis la jeune génération
mais ce que vous deviez vous aussi que
copé c'est le conduit à des militants et
françois fillon candidat des barons
justement cela a été dit et redit
écoutez j'ai de l'estimé du respect pour
françois fillon c'est quelqu'un qui a
des grandes capacités et il a dans ses
équipes et des militants et de marans
donc tout ça est une question de dosage
je ne veux pas en rajouter sur ce sujet
alors en tout cas j'ai nous voulons
après cette campagne rassembler tout le
monde donc je ne peux pas de phrases
définitives mais je voulais dit et je me
suis suffisamment gâchée pour vous dire
très clairement que pour moi jean
françois copé pouvait tête un avenir que
je pense qu'il a des chances de gagner
les différences de fond les ai saisies
pas forcément fragile courant c'est très
important parce que vous savez on vient
vous souvenez du rpr de l'udf vous
souvenez de ces batailles politiques
rassemblées dans une famille non pas sur
une ligne politique monolithique et qui
pourrait à un moment ou un autre
caporaliser tout le monde c'est un
risque mais vous le dire et nous
associons hendrix en moi j'ai pas trouvé
suffisamment dans les équipes
gouvernementales de nicolas sarkozy et
françois fillon je n'ai pas trouvé assez
de diversité la même famille politique
historique a été très représenté dans
toute l'histoire de ces cinq dernières
années
moi je pense qu'à l'avenir il faut
travailler davantage toutes les
diversités les vous craignent justement
que si françois fillon est élu c'est
courant de rien si françois fillon est
élu c'est françois fillon est élu la
démocratie lors a choisi et il sera le
président donc il est clair que je n'ai
pas peur ni de crâne mais je pense que
la diversité
elle passe par les courants et ce que je
constate c'est que fo jean françois copé
y est favorable et que françois fillon
est plutôt ont affronté nicolas va peser
mais c'est en fait le un peu le fantôme
cette élection est ce que vous pensez
que
il va revenir écoutez il ne me paraît
pas absents j'ai le sentiment qu'il
s'intéresse toujours à la politique
et j'entends beaucoup de gens sur le
terrain qui font référence à lui y
compris d'ailleurs le nouveau
gouvernement qui agit mal à sortir de
son face à face avec nicolas sarkozy
donc je pense que nicolas sarkozy reste
en effet dans notre paysage politique
est ce que ce sera bien pour lui et ce
sera bien pour le pays le temps le dira
et les beaucoup de trop tôt pour
vraiment exercice d'écouté je peux avoir
des contacts avec lui je suis en
situation où les uns et les autres
peuvent me parler de lui donc je ne suis
pas vraiment en état de manque non est
ce qu'il manque au débat politique dans
ce pays bas je pense qu'il a créés et
quand même une forme de gouvernement
liés aux cures 1 juillet à l'audace
liées à l'énergie qui fait que quand on
voit un gouvernement partir en vacances
on se dit tiens pour la géorgie
il était il avait arrêté ses vacances
tient il avait pris des options
courageux sur tel ou tel sujet dire que
jamais nicolas sarkozy et est
indifférent à l'actualité
on avait un peu le sentiment cet été que
l'exécutif était un peu aux abonnés
absents et de manière générale ce que
vous croyez au retour d un providentiel
vous je pense que les circonstances vont
tellement vite je pense que les la
situation politique d'une a tellement
complexe que les jeunes générations
aujourd'hui arrivent dans notre société
je pense en effet que l'aspiration
renouvellement risque d'être dominant
mais personne ne peut savoir dans quelle
situation nous serons et en plus je
pense que la crise que nous avons devant
nous qui est devant nous c'est pour ça
que tout à l'heure je regrettais que le
gouvernement ne placez pas la crise
vraiment au bon niveau c'est à dire au
niveau européen et pas seulement au
niveau des emplois jeunes bien sûr qu au
niveau de la flexibilité bien sûr mais
d'abord au niveau européen
je pense que dans ce contexte la de
crise on peut avoir besoin de recours ça
s'est vu dans le passé
merci beaucoup d'être sûr de votre
successeur dominique de villepin qui a
été entendu
en garde à vue d'ailleurs un temps par
les gendarmes dans la sphère des relais
châteaux il est soupçonné d'avoir exercé
des pressions en faveur de son ami régis
bulot qui était le dirigeant à l'époque
de cette chaîne hôtelière et qui
lui-même est soupçonné d'avoir procédé à
des détournements de fonds un ancien
premier ministre comme ça entendu par
les gendarmes
écoutez je ne connais rien à cette
affaire que la justice fasse son travail
sur un plan personnel ça peut pas être
une nouvelle qui me réjouit ce qu'arnaud
de public sénat donc va nous rejoindre
maintenant pour évoquer le sénat
maintenant jean pierre raffarin
objectifs 2014 pour la droite des tons
qui s'imagine déjà reprendre le flambeau
à mme tran huy c'est la dure loi de la
politique
aussitôt élu aussitôt honni le président
et sa majorité font face à l'impatience
des français dont la déception pointe
déjà l'opposition se voit déjà gagné les
élections intermédiaires mais le
gouvernement avertit ça ne se passera
pas comme ça
j'ai tout à fait légitime pour une
formation politique d'avoir de désespoir
voilà ceci étant entre l'espoir et la
concrétisation il il ya beaucoup de
preuves à faire à l'égard de celles et
ceux qui vont voter pas encore de
preuves mais dans le groupe ump du sénat
on prédit des difficultés pour la gauche
horizon 2014 les élections municipales
en 2014 sont en effet positionné à un
moment du quinquennat qui devrait
permettre à l'opposition de se refaire
des forces
or les élections municipales ont un
impact immédiat sur les sénatoriales
puisque la haute assemblée et élus
essentiellement par les délégués des
conseils municipaux l'opposition prédit
des difficultés pour la majorité et a
peu de chances de se tromper
2014 c'est surtout le milieu du mandat
de françois hollande
traditionnellement le creux de la vague
dans un quinquennat présidentiel
on sait qu'au cours du quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy les élections
intermédiaires ont pratiquement toutes
été perdus par la droite
et peut-être que ces élections
intermédiaires signifieront
un retour de balancier en défaveur du
parti au pouvoir en défaveur de la
gauche alors le sénat pourrait t'il à
nouveau tourner à droite trois ans
seulement après son basculement à gauche
le sénat de gauche ne sera qu il qu'une
parenthèse dans l'histoire de la haute
assemblée voilà perrine tarneaud est
avec nous aux personnes qui suit de très
près l'actualité sénatoriales et la
rentrée a été pour le moins houleuse ce
mardi un peu avant de parler des
prochaines élections sénatoriales jean
pierre raffarin c'est ouverture très
agité la session extraordinaire cet
après midi au sénat on a vu que les
appels règlement se sont multipliés à
droite comme à gauche d'ailleurs sur
l'examen en urgence du texte sur le
logement est ce que vous estimez que le
sénat n'est pas été assez respectés par
le gouvernement dans cette procédure
votre est franchement tous les
gouvernements ont tendance à vouloir un
peu malmené le parlement avec la
procédure d'urgence on utilise beaucoup
trop quand j'étais premier ministre j'ai
veillé à limiter un peu ce recours à
l'urgence il est clair que le parlement
après si peu qu'on ait des grandes
périodes sans texte qu'on a des grandes
périodes pratiquement sans travail et
d'un seul coup on nous demande de
travailler dans le genre depuis la
naissance ont même pas eu le temps de
faire leur rapport sur ce texte est une
première dans l'histoire du sénat sur
cette non respect du parlement et c'est
je crois qu'on est en train de payer
cette léthargie estivale où elle le
pouvoir à peu travaillé et maintenant va
accélérer et tout ça donne le sentiment
d'être un peu improvisé est complètement
désormais l'urgence pour le logement
social a été soulignée mais l'urgence on
peut très bien travailler vite mais dans
l'organisation et avec concertation et
je pense que ils auraient pu être utiles
par exemple de travailler sur ces sujets
au mois de juillet et on aurait pu
reprendre plus tôt en septembre si on
devait apprendre mais au fond les textes
n'étaient pas prêts et donc on se trouve
dans une situation qui est une citation
d'improvisation sur le fond du texte est
ce que vous êtes favorable à plus de
sanctions envers les mères qui ne
respectent pas les quotas de logements
sociaux sur leur commune de cette très
compliqué parce que ça va dépendre des
quelques hôtes à ce qu'on pense à 25% et
quels critères donc pour les granges aux
chercheuses gens mais parlant pendant
toutes les circonstances et donc il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont en
discussion et notées notamment de devoir
en fonction des villes et en heure
l'écart par exemple entre les loyers
sociaux les loyers du privé peut être un
paramètre d'arbitrage donc j'attends de
voir le thème général est ce que de
savoir qu'en plus de sanctions est ce
qu'on incite les maires à construire
d'une manière je vais m'associer à faire
qu'on est si par des avantages plutôt
qu'on fasse de la répression que la mise
à disposition gratuite dit-on le terrain
oui mais il faudrait que c'est le
gouvernement soit un peu plus clair
qu'il ne l'a été jusqu'à maintenant sur
la la capacité à libérer des terrains
donc tout ceci est pas préparé tout ceci
est anticipée donc j'attendrai la fin
les réalisations finalement de cette
union est une improvisation regrettable
en tout cas c'est pas du bon travail
législatif sur l'ambiance au sénat dans
une interview au figaro il ya deux
semaines gérard larcher a regretté que
le sénat soit devenu la maison du
silence est ce que vous partagez cette
position avec lui on trouve qu'on a été
silencieux parce qu'en effet pendant
toute cette période il n'y a pas eu
beaucoup de travail parlementaire mais
ce silence du sénat avait comme premier
responsable
l'exécutif le gouvernement qui n'a pas
donné des textes et en général je me
souviens quand j'étais premier ministre
en 2002 mais je me souviens après -
françois fillon
je me souviens y compris de lionel
jospin en 97 les premiers les premières
semaines d'un nouveau pouvoir
on met tout de suite en oeuvre par des
textes importants et donc là on a eu le
sentiment qu'il n'y avait rien de très
important pendant ses cent premiers
jours à lima dans le mans terre aurait
pu prendre l'initiative à écouter les
parlementaires monté il ya un grand
nombre de propositions de lois qui sont
proposées aujourd'hui au débat que le
gouvernement n'ait three pas à l'ordre
du jour donc je prends vraiment
aujourd'hui que le parlement est prêt à
travailler mais que le gouvernement doit
lui aussi se mettent au travail
en tout cas on voit que gérard larcher
se positionne toujours en vue d'un
éventuel basculement basculement du
sénat à nouveau à droite en 2014
est-ce que vous même
et à marquer que je n'y a pas que le
duel peut-être copé fillon il y en a
d'autres qui se produit avec la
restaurer nous nous verrons je pense
qu'il n'est pas ni courtois vis-à-vis du
président actuel qui est en compte son
mandat de tout de suite chercher à le
déstabiliser faut que le sénat
fonctionne normalement donc je trouve
que le président du sénat a fait
fonctionner le sénat comme il se doit
donc je n'ai pas à mener une guérilla
interne je pense d'autre part qu' au
lendemain d'une défaite électorale il
vaut mieux analyser les raisons de
l'échec de partir aussitôt à la conquête
comme ça en dix ans maintenant c'est à
nous il faut être capable d'avoir un
discours qui va convaincre les maires
qui va nous permettre de gagner les
municipales d'avoir une attitude au
parlement constructive et c'est si nous
sommes capables de dégager ce message
positif et constructif que nous pourrons
gagner des municipales est envisagé
l'alternance aussi je pense que la
manière dont on a traité les élus locaux
la manière dont on a traité les locaux 3
3 mois 6 mois avant les élections
sénatoriales un but à vécu je l'avais
déjà levé je l'avais déjà dit on a
plutôt donné que perdu le sénat
je me suis déjà exprimé sur ce sujet
donc je pense qu'un certain nombre
d'erreurs ont été tagués faudra les
corriger
il faut respecter les collectivités
locales il faut avoir des projets
d'avenir
il faut que nous nous soyons porteurs de
ces projets donc avec gérard larcher et
avec les autres nous devons construire
ce projet qui nous conduira peut-être à
l'alternance n'ont fait pas de
l'alternance le préalable ont fait du
projet le préalable
mais pour éviter cette alternance la
majorité actuelle pourrait modifier le
mode de scrutin
cela nous nous attendons à combler ma
liste de sa part donc on on pense en
effet que nous aurons quelques malice de
mode de scrutin qui seront changés mais
je commence quand j'ai vu les retards du
parti socialiste car ils ont gagné
le sénat je me doute qu'ils vont tout
faire pour essayer d'un point le perdre
donc ça nous nous certainement que nous
aurons des situations assez malicieuse
avec un changement de loi électorale
avec sans doute un certain nombre
d'artifice pour que la gauche puisse
conserver puis nous verrons ça le moment
venu moi je ne souhaite pas que le sénat
dans cette période nouvelles
apparaissent comme un lieu de polémique
comme un lieu de tension nous sommes des
élus républicains
notre pays dans une situation très grave
nous devons faire fonctionner le sénat
nous devons respecter les votes
démocratiques nous devons d'exprimer en
liberté et pour nous gens de
l'opposition
notre travail n'est pas celui de la
guérilla notre travail est de construire
des projets d'avenir et de nous montrer
crédible vis-à-vis des français pour
l'avenir et donc je ne suis pas
favorable à ce que tous les jours on
transforme le sénat en un champ de
bataille au contraire que ce soit plutôt
un champ d'avenir c'est pour ça que vous
voterez avec la gauche le traité
européen
le texte somme serait bien européen bien
sûr que je voudrais le traité européen
je pense que c'est un texte très
important j'aurais préféré qu'on ait la
loi constitutionnelle plutôt qu'à loi
organique la loi organique elle n'a pas
la puissance qui aurait convaincu et les
allemands et nos partenaires y compris
les marchés donc je pense que là il ya
une erreur mais ce n'est pas parce qu'il
ya une erreur que je vais freiner la
dynamique européenne qui est nécessaire
au pays donc bien sûr que je voterai ce
texte européen quand je dis que je vote
pour les emplois jeunes je ne les
emplois d'avenir maintenant je ne sais
pas parce que je partage cette mesure
mais à partir du moment où le décide le
président de la république élu de
manière décidée ce type d'initiative moi
sur le terrain je ne veux pas être celui
qui empêchera un certain nombre de
jeunes d'avoir accès à cette première
expérience
donc ça ne veut pas dire que j'adhère je
suis un élu responsable qui pense aux
français plus qu'au pouvoir
est-ce que vous adhérez au prochain
projet de loi pour limiter voire
interdire le cumul des mandats c'est ça
c'est très difficile moi je pense que
vous savez je ne suis pas en situation
de cumul moi je n'ai qu'un mandat donc
je pourrais très facilement favorable à
ça mais en tout cas si notre pays était
très décentralisé je préférais mais
aujourd'hui tout se décide encore à
paris notre pays n'est pas suffisamment
décentralisée est donc temps que le pays
ne sera pas suffisamment décentralisée
je souhaite que l'élu est un mandat
national est amendable
avoir un statut particulier pour les
sénateurs par rapport aux députés ça
finit par y ça ne me paraît pas choquant
je sais que les députés ne sont pas du
tout satisfaits de cette idée mais ce
que je trouve un peu absurde c'est que
le maire qui votent pour le sénateur
n'aurait pas le droit d'être sénateur
parce que le jour où l'utilisateur est
bien plus mr donc si le maire qui est
dans le corps électoral qui lie le
sénateur n'a pas le droit d'être
sénateur ou s'il devient sénateur il
peut plus être maire je trouve que c'est
quelque chose qui est paradoxal nous
sommes élus par les maires qu'on puisse
savoir un mandat de maire ne me paraît
pas du tout chaud quand bien au
contraire est une position forte au sein
du groupe socialiste est notamment
défendue par françois rebsamen
est-ce que vous voterez le mariage gay
ça nous en discuterons moi je ne pense
pas que je le voudrais
je ne pense pas que je le voterai nous
nous en discuterons on va on va voir un
peu les uns les autres mais il s'agit là
de sujets très personnelle des sujets de
conviction sur lesquelles toutes les
positions sont tout à fait respectable
et je pense qu'il faut être dans une
position très ouvert moi la difficulté
que j'ai avec ce sujet c'est que le
mariage parce que je suis catholique le
mariage est un sacrement pour quelqu'un
de catholiques donc c'est un sujet sur
l'appellation donc ce qui est un
problème qui mérite débat mais je suis
pas du tout fermé à l'idée social du
sujet donc c'est un c'est un sujet sur
lequel nous débattrons pour lequel moi
je n'ai pas de aucune crispation
je pense que c'est notre société doit se
débarrasser à peu près un sujet pareil
de conviction de cette nature comme
comme on a eu des des sujets qui sont
des sujets des tic des sujets de morale
des sujets qui sont sur le plan social
très important
moi je suis favorable à ce qu'il y ait
une liberté de conscience par exemple
dans la motion d humanisme et libéraux
que nous avons signé avec jean leonetti
luc chatel et quelques autres on sur ces
sujets là nous voulons respecter la
liberté de vote de chacun jean pierre
raffarin une question avec notre
partenaire orange et l'application tivi
tchèque c'est une question de irma vous
avez accepté une mission sur l'algérie
pour laurent fabius est ce que vous êtes
prêts à soutenir martine aubry qui elle
va travailler
sur la chine vous qui êtes un grand
spécialiste de la chine un grand
connaisseur de la chine
alors d'abord la mission sur l'algérie
c'est la prolongation d'une mission que
m'avait confié nicolas sarkozy il ya
deux ans et pour lequel il ya encore
quelques travaux à faire acheter
donc j'ai accepté de poursuivre cette
mission et j'ai appelé martine aubry
pour lui dire que j'étais tout à fait
disposé à travailler avec elle sur les
relations avec la chine très souvent de
manière très positive nous verrons sans
doute prochainement dès qu'elle sera
libérée de ses fonctions par yves
jeanneret partira dès qu'elle sera
libérée nous nous verrons ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que depuis très
longtemps
les dirigeants chinois m'ont toujours
dit qu'il souhaitait avoir une
personnalité socialiste qui
s'intéressait relations franco chinoises
il souffrait d'un déficit de
considérations bien ou la chine
il n'y a pas dans le foot après
l'introduction alors m'écouter d'une
conforter nos ambiances sujet en tout
cas je vais vous dire je mets la
politique étrangère de mon pays à
l'extérieur des polémiques ce sont des
sujets difficiles qui ne se règle pas en
un mandat et ce sont des sujets sur
lequel on doit avoir une certaine
distance vis-à-vis de la polémique
et si madame aubry peut faire du travail
utile pour la france quand chine
je ne vais pas l'empêcher d'agir piano
contraire vous la grue était volontiers
et donc quand françois hollande se
rendra en algérie vous participerez à ce
voyage officiel à ses côtés je n'ai pas
été invité nous verrons mais en tout cas
je vous dis très clairement je ne mets
pas la politique étrangère au coeur des
polémiques ce sont des sujets très
compliqué ce sont des sujets qui
demandent des années des années
d'expertisé des mouvements historiques
qui sont très compliquées je pense qu'il
faut vis-à-vis de l'état français une
continuité et en ce qui me concerne je
me réjouis de voir que dans la vème
république globalement malgré les
alternances
il ya une certaine qu'on paye à paris
plus de la politique étrangère que vous
mettez hors des polémiques jean pierre
raffarin vous écoute depuis le début de
cette émission on l'a vu sur les emplois
d'avenir vous allez voter
vous êtes associé vous soutenez jean
françois copé qui lui est partisan d'une
opposition vraiment frontale un presque
violente avec l'exécutif vous vous êtes
quand même un peu engagés vous dire il a
besoin de moi et moi et moi j'ai rejoint
parce qu'il a besoin de gens qui autour
de lui nous rencontrons des attitudes
des convictions et les humanistes se
sentent bien à côté de jean françois
copé est même s'il ya des humanistes
comme jean leonetti qui soutiennent
françois fillon met donc moi je pense
que jean françois copé va organiser les
courants pour ça il est adepte de la
diversité et comme il est généreux d'un
côté mais très direct de l'autre il est
assez cash comme on dit c'est assez
facile d'être à ses côtés
c'est assez facile de faire en sorte
qu'ils vous écoute très carrée et vous
vous apportez des rondeurs exactement
vous avez tout fait l'image qu'on va
retenir absolument
donc il a vraiment besoin vous et si je
peux lui apporter aussi un peu
d'expérience et puis ce goût de l'avenir
j'ai ce bout de l'international de
l'ouverture mais je trouve que c'est
quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui rassemble il
est capable de réunir et au fond c'est
un bon manager c'est un bon chef de
parti je pense que la solitude n'est pas
bonne conseillère pour diriger une
famille politique
merci beaucoup jean pierre raffarin
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui vous
étiez donc le premier invité de la
nouvelle saison de preuves par 3 merci
perrine merci à nos partenaires agence
france presse et puis donc l'application
tvcheck d'orange et on se retrouve ici
même à la semaine prochaine bonsoir à
tous
se renseigner sur les programmes
voir ou revoir les émissions suivre les
fils d'information politique et
parlementaire pour vivre la politique en
temps réel
connectez vous et réagissez sur
publicsenat.fr
chaque année 70 mille personnes sont
hospitalisées sans leur consentement
alors que la loi qui encadre ces
hospitalisations vient d'être réformé la
réalisatrice lorène debaisieux a enquêté
sur le monde de la psychiatrie
j'avais envie de parler d'un sujet qui
me semble encore très tabou
je pense que la folie fait peur encore
aujourd'hui et que j'avais envie de
parler des fractures de la société s'en
fait partie et je pense que c'est une
manière de décrire la société que de
raconter comment la société traite c'est
fou c'est un engin durant dans des
prisons aussi c'est une façon de voir
quel est le niveau d'une société
exactement par de voir comment elle gère
à la marge les personnes ne sont pas
dans le circuit de pala commun sur les
rives et libertés
c'est un enjeu important parce que il ya
à peu près 70 mille personnes qui sont
hospitalisées sous contrainte par an et
que ça correspond à peu près au nombre
de personnes qui sont incarcérés
équivalent donc c'est vrai que c'est
comparable
l'enjeu est important et il nous voilà
nous semblait important de donner la
parole aux personnes concernées
assia ce qui est dur dans l'histoire
mais vous êtes la mère d'un enfant comme
ça qu'on demande à hospitaliser c'est
quoi c'est la trahison qu'on semble lui
faire c'est de la peur de se tromper
c'est quoi et là je n'ai pas peur de me
tromper toute façon je suis pas tout
seul dans le cas d'une mère ne veut pas
hospitaliser son enfant de force il n'ya
pas l'avis du psychiatre
donc il ya des médecins qui vous appuyez
ou chivu non qu'ils disent oui mais il
n'ya pas que vous vous vous le demander
mais bon ce qui est c'est vous voyez
votre enfant partir dans une ambulance
en ayant une piqûre calmantes de force
dans la fesse voilà il vous suivez vous
arrivez en pleine nuit dans un hôpital
psychiatrique que ce soit sainte anne où
paul girot d'autres c'est quand même un
peu style asile du 19e siècle
donc voilà ma fille me disait tu m'as
fait interner chez les fous non je t'ai
fait hospitaliser parce que tu es malade
et on a besoin de vous le reprocher une
usine
plusieurs fois c'est terrible pour avoir
la conscience après récupérer elle
comprend pas elle veut pas et puis petit
à petit petit à petit il ya quand même
une espèce de compréhension que ça n'est
pas vraiment pour lui faire du mal et
que l y trouve aussi elle a fait la
démarche elle-même parfois d'y aller
seul vous en même temps aujourd'hui
elles et eux une hospitalisation libre a
commencé sa joie zidi à l'ewi danse est
une évolution dans son entraînement et
dans son état oui il serait une calade
dominique au fil du temps que vous
l'ayez fait le bon choix que d'appeler
des médecins pour la contraindre à se
faire soigner
oui c'est ça oui en gros c'est ça oui
concrètement comment ça se passe quand
on rentre comme ça hospitalisés
allemande d'un tiers ou d'office dans un
hôpital
on n'est pas libre on est enfermé on est
contrat on est attaché on affame heures
dans une chambre et quoi on est avant
tout protéger c'est le mou mais concret
viendront la vérité c'est quoi pour
protéger ma vérité des faits mais dans
toute la médecine il ya des mesures qui
sont prises quand on reçoit quelqu'un
qui est à moitié dans le coma ou d'un
panda on va prendre toutes les
dispositions pour qu'ils se fassent pas
de mal en tombant
nous nous devons faire en sorte que
puisqu'il n'est pas conscient des
troubles dont il souffre qu' il ne
paraît ne quitte pas l'hôpital
immédiatement qu'il ne ne se fasse pas
du mal qu'il ne fasse pas de mal à
d'autres patients enfin c'est toutes ces
mesures de relance alors d'incarcération
mais on est on est calme dans une
logique de privation de contraintes
on peut on leur enlevait un traitement à
quelqu'un qu'il refuse on peut le faire
à tous les usages et toutes les règles
on peut le voir sous ce regard là mais
non mais c'est la panique
mais c'est une protection nécessaire et
qui n'est pas discutable jusque
l'arrivée du juge c'est très très
difficile à vivre pour les psychiatres
qui jusqu'à présent était un peu maîtres
chez eux et qu'ils sont même maintenant
obligés effectivement de justifier
encore une fois la privation de liberté
nous avons eu de longs débats à
l'assemblée pour savoir si le juge
devait aussi intervenir dans
l'obligation de soins il nous est apparu
nous députés toutes tendances politiques
confondues
l'obligation de soin à domicile et à
l'extérieur à l'extérieur à quelques
nouveautés de la loi aussi un
dépendre membre obligé déçoit mais là il
n'ya pas le regard du juge pour
l'instant dépendamment voilà de la
privation de liberté il nous a semblé
que le juge n'avait pas à intervenir sur
l'obligation de soin ça c'est le rôle du
médecin ce rôle du psychiatre
à côté de ça la notion de privation de
liberté elle est fondamentale et ça ce
n'est pas du ressort du médecin c'est
vraiment du ressort du juge de savoir si
je suis là juste mon patient est en
mesure ou pas de sortie alors ça se
passe plus ou moins bien selon que les
juges se déplace à l'hôpital ou pas nous
avons aujourd'hui dans les auditions que
nous avons mené le premier bilan montre
qu environ 30% des juges se déplace dans
les hôpitaux et dans ce cas là ça se
passe globalement très bien est ce
qu'ils comprennent bien vous êtes de
leur côté par en face et comment ça se
passe ce qu'ils sont vraiment à skis et
c'est ce que revendique ses tresses est
très variable et dire qu'il ya les tout
une certain nombre de patients qu'ils
comprennent pourquoi ils sont là et
toute une autre partie qui n'est pas
d'accord d'ailleurs il ya eu
hospitalisations sans consentement c'est
bien qu'au départ le patient n'était pas
n'était pas consentante mais au bout de
15 jours parce que nous nous intervenons
quand même quasiment au bout de 15 jours
et va pas pas toujours pas toujours pas
toujours mais en tout cas on sait quoi
je vois quand même un certain nombre de
personnes qui n'étaient pas d'accord
pour être hospitalisés qui dit jour
twitter haber adhère voilà et j'aime mon
quartier mais vous en libérer en premier
mais combien alors c'est à peu près saga
6% 5 à 6%
de manly évaluations en primaire
enfin stressé par an compétitif l'école
est elle en panne
ils ont débattent sur le plateau d'
élise lucet
j'ai trois enfants donc deux plus grands
19 et 16 ans et un plus petit qui a 6
ans et j'ai été très frappée parce que
donc les trois on n'a pas changé de
quartier on est resté dans la même école
et à dix ans d'intervalle je n'ai pas
reconnu la maternelle c'est à dire que
effectivement notre fils revenait en
disant que la journée qu'est ce que tu
fais je travaille je travaille donc
avait pas de jeu donc j'ai d'abord pensé
que c'était peut-être cette maîtresse
après je me suis c'est peut-être cette
école et puis j'ai commencé à me
renseigner j'ai rencontré notamment des
chercheurs donc christophe joigneaux qui
est universitaire est qui et qui faisait
une étude sur justement le l'utilisation
des fiches en maternelle et comment on
voit là il ya de moins en moins
d'activités de manipulation d'activités
créatrices de dessin libre par exemple
on n'a quasiment plus ça m'a vraiment
frappé mais dès la moyenne section c'est
à dire que